thank you everyone great too great to be
her and great to see you all here so I'm
going to talk a little bit about the
past the present in the future of the
cloud and especially how it relates to
how we access the cloud and the devices
that we use to access the cloud so I'm
going to start with the past this is the
very very old google apps logo and so
ten years ago right now this week we
were doing our very first customer
pitches of Google Apps and I remember it
very distinctly because I flew to New
York with little bit more little more
than a slide deck with the idea of
talking to a bunch of CIOs and trying to
convince them to move their email to our
data centers and the cloud wasn't even a
concept really at the time and you know
people talk about things like SAS but
the cloud really wasn't a concept so we
went up and down Manhattan with about a
dozen customer visits and I will never
forget the very last one so we walk into
a big company go to the boardroom and
talk to the CIO of this big company he
walks in I go to slide number one start
to talk about the concept of what we're
talking about and he stops me on slide
one and he says okay let me understand
this you want me to move my data to your
data centers I said yes and so he said
he thought about it he gave me a
quizzical look and he got up and he said
I'm sorry not interested just left the
room and I was you know relatively young
product manager at the time and I was
just stunned my brand new product here
the guy didn't want it nobody wanted it
and so I can't started thinking you know
maybe I'm crazy maybe this thing isn't
really going anywhere it what have I
gotten myself into well turns out it
wasn't that crazy and turns out this
cloud thing maybe have it may have a
future here as well too but you know in
all seriousness it's amazing to see kind
of in the 10 years that's passed how
much the cloud has evolved it's gone
from something that's been on the fringe
to something that's mainstream and we've
gone from the concept of thinking about
what can you do on one two or three
servers to what can
you do on a thousand service or ten
thousand servers are a hundred thousand
servers and that is it opens up a whole
set of new possibilities one of the most
profound transitions though has been in
the devices that we use to access the
cloud so I think about that meeting ten
years ago and we were all walking in
with laptops and all of my data was on
that laptop if I lost that laptop I
wouldn't be able to do any work anymore
where is now we move from device to
device to device we can have low powered
handheld devices where I can access all
the world's information I can access
every email I've ever written every
document that's ever been shared to me
every photo I've ever taken every song
I've ever listened to things like that
are just absolutely astounding it's all
because of the cloud and so the question
is is that now where do we go from here
and how do we make it such that
everybody has access to the cloud so the
question I want to pose to you is what
would happen if everyone at your
business had access to the cloud at all
times and when I say everyone I don't
just mean the people with desks I mean
every employee and I don't just mean
every employee I also mean what about
your customers to people that might walk
into a store front for example what
would happen if everybody had access to
the cloud so imagine if that were the
case so in I'll take I'll take the
example which you just saw imagine if
every student in the school had access
to the cloud at all times you could
transform how a school works you can
take curriculum and you can cater it to
the needs of every single student you
can actually bring in interactive
interactive content that would be
incredibly engaging for a student and
we've seen this now happen where test
scores are going up we're we're
engagement is going up and students are
learning in a very different way imagine
if you had a store and in that store
every customer that walked in and every
employee had access to the cloud at all
times the employ the the customers can
walk in and have engaging experiences
with kiosks for example where they can
access all the information they need to
research their purchase they'll know
about things that are on your shelf and
things that may not be on your show and
they may be
able to make a purchase decision
actually build loyalty and engagement in
a much better way your employees will
have quicker access to knowledge of
anything that they need and be able to
serve the customer better and processes
that used to be on paper can now be
automated things like everything from HR
processes to time cards to shift
scheduling can all be automated
processes things like that that that
they can really transform a business and
create business value but the truth is
is that that's actually not what's
happening right now so there are about
3.2 billion 3.25 billion workers that
walk into a workplace every single day
but about 75% of those workers don't
have a desk and they're only about 750
million pcs in business today too and as
much as we talk about the smartphone
even though there are almost two billion
consumers that have smartphones there
are only about 300 million managed
smartphones in businesses today and so
we need to do more to try to make that
vision take route to bring the cloud to
to more people so this is really what
we've been thinking about with our
device platforms and so Chrome OS and
Android the great thing that we've been
able to do is we've been able to grow
grow up and in the in the age of the
cloud these operating systems were
started in the age of the cloud so we
can design it from the ground up with
the cloud in mind and as a result of
that we can extend it to the future of
where devices are going and that future
really falls into three buckets and this
is what we're focusing on in terms of
how do we actually evolve our products
the first is mobility for all how do we
bring the idea of mobility at every
single user second is redefining the
concept of productivity the pc is
something that that that is evolving
extremely rapidly and it's still very
important but important in a very
different way and i'll go into kind of
what that means and the third thing is
beyond mobility how do we actually go
beyond mobility and actually start to
bring this to new devices that are very
different so first part about bringing
mobility to all
a key lesson here is that one size
doesn't fit all you can't just have one
type of mobile device that that is the
same for everyone that you might give
for example to your CEO but then you
also might give to for example somebody
on the on the shop floor and this is the
thing we've really focused on with
Android how can we have the operating
system be the same but how do we make it
such that there are a plethora of
devices that are out there so with
Android the great thing we have is we
have almost thousand OEMs that are
actually building devices of all kinds
of various types and these are just a
few of the examples that are there and
there are you know very very premium
devices they're inexpensive devices
there are tablets they're big phones
there are small phones there are rugged
devices all kinds of things that would
actually make it such that it fits the
particular business need that you have a
great example of this is this contrast
right here so on one side you have the
nexus 6p which you all got today we took
care to put the most premium materials
in there the best possible camera we can
find the best possible display we can
find making it such that it's an
incredible experience for the top end
user on the other side you have a phone
that dewalt produced and dewalt as you
as many of you know produces
construction tools but they actually
also produced a phone and this phone
meets the needs of what's needed for a
construction worker on the on the job
site at a particular time this is the
kind of phone that you can drop from a
building and it'll be safe you can dump
it in a vat of water and it'll be safe
it has a set of peripherals on it that
are needed for the construction site for
example you'll be able to actually do
measurements using this phone things
like that that are very specific to that
need and with Android you have that
plethora of areas out there this is the
kind of area where we're looking forward
to evolving how can we meet the needs of
more employees we're very excited about
the partnership we announced earlier
today with Accenture in mobility that we
can now start to go after very specific
use cases and start to bring mobility as
a much bigger part of those use cases
the second part is how do we redefine
the pc and so one exercise that we took
is
if we redefine the pc what would that
what would it be if we had to start from
the ground up what would that what would
that be and how would we look at it
differently so the first three things we
thought of is that it needs to be fast
you need to be able to get into what
you're doing very quickly and start
being productive it needs to be easy and
it needs to be secure from from the very
GetGo you shouldn't have to be worrying
about viruses and playing whack Amole
with viruses it should just be secure
from the from the get-go and so that's
how we design Chrome OS to begin with
but then three other things we thought
it need to be shareable because in the
world where you're using many devices
you may not want to give a PC to every
single person you want to make it such
that you have a bank of devices that
people can use whenever they need to you
want to make it get better over time the
wonderful thing about the cloud is that
it just gets better over time Gmail will
ship a new feature every single week and
make it better and better and better why
isn't your PC like that it needs to be
like that in the last things it needs to
be versatile meaning that you need to be
able to use it as a mobile device but
you also need to be able to use as a
productive device it needs to switch
whenever you need to so two aspects I
want to drill into a little bit the
shareability this has been one thing
that has really made Chromebooks very
very successful in in US schools and so
Chromebooks now represent about sixty
percent of the devices that are in in US
schools and we've seen an enormous
amount of impact there but the way that
that started is a teacher would buy what
we call here a chrome cart with about 30
Chromebooks roll it into the classroom
when the class starts student would go
and pick up any Chromebook open it up
log in and within five seconds they're
into their into their applications they
do what they need to do in the classroom
return it at the end of the class the
next class walks in and then the next
slide and then next time those students
pick it up pick that up so within a day
you might hit a hundred and eighty
students with the same fast set of 30
Chromebooks and so scenarios like this
really open up the possibilities what
you can do with even less budget so a
great example of this is east leyden
high school so east leyden high school
did this with their their science
classes in chicago and they now are
using
books to let their students be able to
actually design artificial limbs and and
be able to actually then go and produce
them and so it's the kind of experience
that I know I never had in school but is
now possible because of the technology
that they have there and the fact that
every student has access to that
technology in that science class but
we're now starting to see this within
businesses as well so a great example of
this is what we're doing with Charles
Schwab so Schwab had a problem where
they wanted to bring more devices into
their branch offices and they also
wanted to have it such that those
devices would be very easy to manage and
and low-cost and have it such that they
could use it but they could also have
the customers use it so they brought
Chromebooks in and what they're doing
with it is that when you walk into a
schwab office and you want to actually
open an account rather than handing you
a stack of papers which we're all used
to they'll hand you a Chromebook you
open it and you actually have your own
private secure session you'll be able to
fill out the information right there
securely submit it and you're done and
there's no there's no manual process
that needs to happen and so they've
found that it's more satisfying for the
users and it's actually a lot more
efficient for them so it's just one
example but they're actually now able to
share that chromebook between customer
to customer and the customer because of
the share ability of Chrome OS so the
second thing I want to emphasize is this
idea of mobile productivity so when you
think of kind of the devices that are
out there are a lot of times you have to
choose between either being mobile or
being productive and so you have tablets
out there that have a vast array of
mobile applications but then they don't
have the ability to really be productive
you know have multi window in
multitasking I'd be able to let you do a
lot of things all at once or you can
choose a PC where you're very very
productive but you don't have those
mobile applications that are out there
and so this is kind of the next frontier
that we're going after with chrome OS we
announced last week that Chromebooks
will now have android apps running in
them on them and the entire Google Play
Store now runs on the Chromebook so the
two million plus apps that we have out
there will run
on the Chromebook seamlessly and so what
this opens up is that is the possibility
for many more types of devices that can
be both a mobile device and a productive
device so this is an example of the the
Chromebook the sous Chromebook flip
where you can turn it into a tablet and
you can turn it into a laptop when it's
in a laptop mode you have multi window
in you can do all the types of desktop
applications you want with things like
virtualization you can be able to access
Windows applications as well but then
you flip it into a tablet and you have
all of the great Android applications
that are out there then make it a great
mobile device and so it's no compromises
lastly how do we go beyond mobility and
what do we do there so the first thing
we're doing here is how do we light up
every screen in your business and so
give you another example of this so this
is an example from from a convenience
store you'll notice the board up there
is a is is an ad and it's a promotion
that they have in the store we've now
made it such that it's easier to make
that a digital sign and it's actually
cheaper to make that a digital sign then
to make it a paper sign we release this
thing last year called the chrome bit
which is an $85 little dongle that you
stick into a screen and it turns it into
a sign or a full computer and so we're
now having it such that people are now
thinking can I take any paper sign I
have and turn it into a digital sign
rotate through the right promotions at
the right time depending on what
inventory I want to push at that
particular time and so one example of
this that that we're working with is
coca-cola so coca-cola just announced a
set of pilots with the albertsons stores
what they're going to be doing is in
about 750 albertsons stores in the drink
aisle they'll be putting a 10 inch
chrome screen there will be a chrome
digital sign they can control that
centrally and push out whatever
promotion they want to those signs the
other interesting part is that on top of
that sign there will be an Eddystone
beacon and when an Eddystone beacon does
is it broadcasts a URL from that
particular sign so when the consumer
goes into that drink island says you
know there's a two-for-one special on
coke zero they can pick out their phone
they'll have a URL that will be there
waiting for the
they can click on that URL and get that
coupon and use it at the checkout stand
immediately and coke can actually rotate
that on a daily or even a
minute-by-minute basis depending on what
they want to want to do and so it opens
up a whole set of new possibilities the
next part of this is what about the
kinds of devices that aren't just mobile
devices and go beyond that to things
like wearables so a few examples here
there are things like watches that that
can be there there are things like for
example other types of specialized
devices for particular areas like
barcode scanners various things like
that there is a whole exciting area
around things like augmented reality and
virtual reality so think about augmented
reality where if you give that to a
field service worker the phone can
actually guide them through a very
complicated repair by actually seeing
what's there and being able to point out
to them exactly what they need to do
those are things that are now going to
be possible with with Android but the
exciting thing is all of these devices
that we can't even dream up today and
we're preparing for that world as well
too we have a project called brillo
which is a which is looking to bring
Android and take Android into these
types of new devices and give you a
platform that can extend to that and we
have a project called weed that that
gives you a communication protocol with
between these devices and makes makes it
says that there's a standard way for
data to flow from those devices into the
cloud and let you let you be able to
actually make the Internet of Things a
reality so the the world of devices this
is kind of where I see things going you
know this could be the dominant set of
devices in five years out there so last
thing I want to talk about is the future
this is my daughter Siona she just
started first grade as you can see from
her little side she she came to that she
came to me a few weeks ago and you know
as many of you guys can relate to I
tried to tell her what I do for a living
and she kind of gets that I build
computers and phones but she mostly
thinks I just go to meetings all day but
a few weeks ago she came to me and and
said daddy can I use a Chromebook I said
where did you learn about this she said
yeah I want to log in with my google
apps account
so oh my god this is crazy and so turns
out at her school they have Chromebooks
they use google apps for a lot of the
things they do she's able to log in and
actually personalized her math lessons
or her reading lessons on Acra on a
Chromebook she uses a thing called I
ready to be able to do math at her own
pace she has this thing called Raz kits
which you can use at home to be able to
actually read books and read from a
massive library books anytime she wants
things like that that I never had when
when I was a kid and I think about the
kinds of things she does she expects
that anywhere she is she can be able to
actually listen to any song that she
wants or that she can say ok Google and
be able to actually get any fact that
she wants at any point in time the
amazing thing is you know 15 years from
now she'll probably be an employee of
one of our companies here 15 years from
now she'll be a probably a customer for
many of your companies as well to where
we as changemakers are building the
world for people like her and all of our
kids where the cloud is just intrinsic
it's always there and so the challenge
for us is how do we make that world take
shape and I think with the technologies
that we have in the mindset that all of
you have we can make that happen thank
you I appreciate it